so yeah let's create on this app she
made something she didn't give it a name
but somebody in her comments called a
pizza roll
so you're gonna get air fryer you're
gonna put your pizza rolls in there on
400 for 10 minutes I use pepperoni
because pepperoni is superior that's
just meat all right so boom after your
pizza rolls are all done and crispy
you're gonna put your mixture on top of
it
and just when you think it's done you're
gonna add some Parmesan cheese
Tina's lady on Facebook she made like a
salmon grilled cheese and I was like
this is the most beautiful first you're
gonna get your salmon I butterfly mine
you don't have to do that and I spray it
with some avocado spray and I seasoned
with everything in my cabinet and pack
it like real good
[Music]
all right
but anyways you're gonna add the best
cheese in the world provolone because
she's Superior she is that girl
[Music]